do you find yourself wanting to take  overwatch on the go well it could happen  I'm Tony this is a GameSpot news update  and for all the biggest Blizzard news be  sure to subscribe  overwatch director Jeff Caplan recently  held an AMA over on reddit and he was  asked about a possible Nintendo switch  version of the game  he didn't completely roll it out in his  response he stated I'm loving the switch  getting overwatch on the switch is very  challenging for us but we're always  open-minded about exploring possible  platforms overwatch is most recent  addition is the defense robot erisa  who's currently available in the game's  public test realm if you want to see her  in action before the full release you  can head over to GameSpot to see all her  skins and emotes plus a handful of  gameplay clips and to keep up with  everything overwatch you're already in  the right place  [Music]